here no tricks no tricks by the stuntman
okay cool let's go here so if I default
if you're I'm just new to it we'll play
a five minute
no increment unrated unless you say
otherwise I'll play faster time controls
but the slowest is just a five minute
all right let's go quit you're talking
quit you're talking and get playing move
your pieces move your pieces let's see
what this is all about here there we go
okay
game 1 against the stuntman Knight f6
and well what do we do we need some more
information here ah I've been playing
this quite a bit for both sides actually
where I just got with the kingside
fianchetto these this Universal set up
basically kingside fiend keto with d6
and I've been doing that actually
against the computer the the beatable
computer but still difficult computer so
I have a lot of practice and I'm stuck
all of a sudden what do you do hmm
to watch out for this let me go at C 6 C
6 and now yeah let's get this in cuz I'm
I'm pretty much saying well you I could
have already said that'll when I play C
6 it's going to now be my e 5 my EEP on
that strikes at the white center so I'm
looking for this setup establish upon on
this square and well depending on what
it is white does I might want to go an
additional step forward so I believe now
I just go ahead and hit at these three
guys and let's see how white reacts if
capture I'm gonna recapture with my pawn
well I better do that otherwise I'm
dropping this and if push that was
another other thing I was gonna say if
push I think I just keep things closed
if I take then I run the risk of what I
run the risk of maybe falling behind
what the development actually because
this is not the most convenient
arrangement here for my Queen Queen side
pieces is it if I take the positions
opening up C file namely and this Bishop
is ready to come out I want to avoid
that so how do I make progress
what is the pawn break I could maybe get
in b5 or f5 which one is more likely of
the two usually b5 is a bit more
difficult to get in when this Bishop is
on its classic diagonal but it's not is
there a way to exploit this diagonal
wait a second there might be I could
maybe snip this pawn Knight takes Knight
takes f5 with E for to follow wait a
second tactics here out of nowhere
you see my mind was not directed in that
I wasn't in that mindset right away I
was looking at pawn breaks but what
about tactical opportunities against
this rook Knight takes Knight takes pawn
push Knight here I have to worry about a
fork I miss square it's not really
working out I think this is purposeful
so maybe I could still get this in and
that I believe it'll just be parried
with the developing move but I think
this is just a good thing not only
flight Square for my King but also just
keeping a night out of g5 okay now I
believe this is working like takes
Knight takes pawn push followed by pawn
push I'm gonna go oh man I shouldn't
have done that I miscalculated I have to
run with that it's okay I believe I do
get the piece back but one thing that I
did forget about is that guy that's just
oh yeah you're gonna wanna hang out of
that deep on next time well done well
done you're gonna want to hang on to
that guy next time so I'm I'm going with
the variation now that's officially
dropping upon oh what a start what a
start yes that Knight is well I'm
actually happy to see this Knight go
somewhere wait a second do I have to
take him what am I afraid of he's not a
wait I'm gonna win a piece now chop this
Knight and then take the rook
you just take that take that guy I'm on
the bishop
there's no rush for taking this clown on
seeing what's he gonna do
grab on 87 if I take this rook the
bishop takes the pawn hits my rook and
hits my bishop in the corner
I can't calculate all this it's too much
calculation for first game
one two three four five six I better I
better take this and run back otherwise
I'm just gonna be down material Bishop
takes pawn I have to come back pretty
sure no wait what am I talk now okay
yeah I'm gonna be up the exchange but
it's still gonna be balance material
here now I'm down at one two three four
five okay yeah my opponent has a minor
piece and two pawns for the rook so
interesting in balance who stands better
now after the smoke clears from all
these in between moves I really don't
know it's a great question but I'm not
gonna be answering all the questions I
ask
let's pre move that right I could do
that who's gonna stand better with this
imbalance listen I believe the the
Bishop has to take and then the knight
has to run away yeah he doesn't he
definitely has to run away the Queen
giving a check I don't know if I'd be
afraid of that he's got a runaway
actually he's gonna be trapped or he's
gonna be sidelined okay check so I just
block with the Queen everybody knows I'm
a fan of Queen exchanges so we're now in
an endgame and game land this is a
connected past pond so I think ideally
I'd like to have my knight right there
to basically say you will go no further
you will stop right in your tracks
it also will stop the Queen from where
you have the Queen stop the bishop from
seeing clear now how do I recapture if I
don't do it though if I do with the rook
stops Knight d6 the knight gets to d6 he
could then run away to b5 because he
comes here and is hitting the pond and
once he's there you can he can run away
I'm not trapping him but what about rook
takes Queen this is the last really big
thing for me
I think rook takes Queen Knight has to
move
kingboo bumps over I'm gonna try that
actually I'm gonna go with this and
attack the night like that the rook
defends I come over and attack it again
if the pond of I think the pond
eventually has to defend I'm gonna play
here I think that's best so that I don't
eventually dispo nice to move and
there's gonna be a bishop check or
something
I am guarding this the knight has to
move I think I could pre move that so
now
oh that's just dropping stuff now that
Knight is cooked so now I'm just up a
full rock and it's much much easier to
pre move okay now this rook is going to
be a beast can't stop this rook I'm
really experiencing a smooth mouse I've
really smooth mouse which is very rare
let's just come over here get preme of
that and this it's pretty much at the
point where I could pre move everything
and actually on chess q okay good game
unchaste q if you pre move right pretty
much not even a point one seconds to
come off your clock which I don't know
if that's the greatest thing in the
world
all right good game let's back up flip
this board clearly is awesome
calculations on my end the white end
this is a very good setup don't really
have any suggestions at this point nice
Center I have to break at it in so I
have to crack at it some way he five is
the way to do it again C six is soon I'm
doing C six if you're playing on the
white side you're seeing your opponent
do this know that this has to be
challenged at some point especially
since as black I'm allowing three
Hanz to just control the center like
that yeah you have to strike at them in
some way so if it's not going to be the
seat pond probably gonna be the e pond
although I guess this is also a
possibility d5 but anyhow 'if I was a d5
and now I close things up because again
I'm not really the side that's going to
be able to do what to complete my
development quicker so I went with c5
and now a miscalculation here this I
should not have done this so there's
some miscalculations that I first had
and then my opponent had so I'm the
first one to commit an error I shouldn't
be going with this tactic because I
think white does well in this variation
after f5 to take on that square and now
in response to e4 what is it that white
should be doing how about this just move
the rook right away don't take this
because the continuation I go forward
with is one that should end up should
end up how it should end up where we
have that imbalance but you can do
better don't get into an imbalance
position just get into one where you are
up upon and I have well I'm still having
to show compensation for it and I simply
don't have compensation for so don't
take this bish up in fact one thing that
you could do is something that I've ever
sized quite a bit in my videos and it's
when you have your opponent in a pin
don't take pin pieces that's like a line
I've said quite a bit
don't take pin pieces well this bishop
in chess terms is not pinned but you can
kind of view it like that because a
pinned piece is one that can't move in
this instance the bishop can't move it's
usually the case that the bishops and
Chad's pin the Knights I'm regarding
this position as the knight pinning the
bishop you know
weird way but anyhow in this in this
position rook rook b1 is going to be
best and I think then the best I could
do is just take the knight you recapture
let's say with the Queen and you could
always in the next turn grab the bishop
if you really wanted to re excuse me
after rugby one pawn takes Knight I
believe it's important to take with the
bishop so that there is not a knight
move with tempo on the Queen that would
allow Queen takes Knight so rook be one
pawn takes Knight is best met with then
I believe pawn takes our Bishop takes
pawn I can't move the pieces so there's
some mental calculation rugby one pawn
takes Knight Bishop takes pawn and if
the knight moves here then you grab the
bishop after the smoke clears you're
just up a clear pond and a very
significant one at that
a connected d5 pawn connected passed
pawn on d5 so with this sequence this is
this is now going to be a problem and at
the very least right now I think just
run away with the night because now with
the the Queen's being challenged all
right even I guess you could have
considered Knight d6 right now since the
Queen is pinned but this starts to not
become a problem since you can't make
use of d6 at the end of the day you're
going to now have to push this pond and
once you lose him I think it's very
difficult yeah you definitely have to
well you can't you can't move the knight
at this point yeah that's why was I
thinking during the game you couldn't
move the knight he's in a pinch so this
is a problem your best way out is to
just run away right now to d6 and then
we still have an interesting game but
now it's me just being up a rook very
soon from here and time wasn't really an
issue okay good game to stuntman
all right